يعني انا كان اكبر مبلغ كان 8,000 ريال
ايوه
كانت لوحه
امراه مع طفل او طفله تحتضن طفله
كانت تمثل لحاله معينه بفتره معينه انا
مررت فيها
عادل الانسان ممكن يبيع لوحاته لانه يقول
لك البعض لا يعني او يعارض المساله هذه
ممكن التكسب المادي من الفن اكيد لكن في
لوحات لا مستحيل انك تبيعيها وتفكر بعض
الاعمال تكون يعني قريبه مني او تمس شيء
مني انت عندك لوحات ممنوع
والرجل ليش غايب عن روحاتك
الرجل مشكله مع الرجل طيب
ابدا ابدا
كثير شو قلت هذا السؤال لكن المراه تمثل
الانسان انا عندي
يعني كلهم
من وين
من المراه هي المراه يعني تمثل الانسان
انا بالنسبه لي يعني ما ماني متحيزه
للمراه ضد الرجل ابدا والمراجعه من الرجل
يعني اذا جينا مساله البيضه ولا الدجاجه
في بعض الاعمال عندي فيها يوجد الرجل
وبصوره جميله ايضا
طيب انا
شاكر مقدمك تواجدك معنا في سؤال مباشر
وتمنيات من الصادقه لك بالتوفيق
ايضا كمعارضه وكلوحات معينه بالتوازي مع
هذه الحاله الفنيه اللي جلسه عيش المملكه
سريعه
الحاله ما شاء الله يعني
احنا عايشين بعد صرصور سرعه الان
واكب لازم نطور ادواتنا ونطور من فنا يعني
المراه الفن بالسعوديه للان لم يصل الى
العالميه اتمنى ان يصل يومنا الايام